the salvation army in middlesbrough
hands out food clothes and toys to the
desperate
since the start of the pandemic the
number of people turning to this line of
last resort
has doubled christmas will be hard
it is all kinds of people that we're
seeing people who have been employed
people who have never been employed
people are street homeless
people who've had stable housing all
sorts of people which is a real
difference for us
kovid has turned chanette basin woods
life upside down
after raising four children as a single
mother she worked hard to build a
business
employing eight staff with a 250 000
pound a year turnover
but then the pandemic hit and her
turnover dropped by two-thirds
my business went from thriving to
literally full stop
within a matter of five days from the
first lockdown
all of a sudden that baby that i had
grown
had all gone and i kind of did think
about the end i thought
i genuinely did and i've got four
children who i
absolutely adore who are adults and you
know that's what
brought me back and my dog as well
she never followed her staff and took a
job in a factory to make ends meet
i was on indeed putting out my cv
and i was having to almost dumb down
my actual qualifications you know
because
people don't want somebody who's run
their own business because they're
probably going to be like super bossy
[Laughter]
they just want somebody to come to work
they couldn't even get like delivery
driver jobs
i'm not a person that can just sit and
kind of cry and hug my pillow
so i thought right let's do something
and the factory was the only
company that was hiring like i just feel
like i'm kind of swimming swimming
swimming
grabbing onto life rafts letting go
going for another life raft and it's
kind of like
could somebody just come and get me back
to my beautiful life please
[Music]
areas of the northeast like
middlesbrough are experiencing job
losses that haven't been seen since
1994.
across the uk more than eight hundred
thousand people have lost their jobs
since the start
of the pandemic but with many still
furloughed and two-thirds of us subject
to the strictest restrictions
economists fear that number will rise
further there's clearly a risk
next year once things start to get back
to normal but we'll see that
some of those millions who have been
furloughed don't actually have a job to
go back to we know that
possibly as many as 2 million have been
followed the whole time since march
now how many of those will be going back
to work
next spring or whenever things start to
get back to normal
we don't know and there's clearly going
to be lots of disruption in the economy
i mean i know it's hard to say because
you know on the one hand the fellow
scheme is really supporting a lot of
people who could be
in a very difficult situation otherwise
but it's expensive and
it's not very targeted i think the
problem with the
the announcement of the continuation of
the furlough scheme is is it really
going to end at the end of april i mean
by the end of april
we've been going for more than a year
now that we actually have a vaccine on
the horizon hopefully we do have an end
in sight when we've got an end in sight
then probably continuing to throw lots
of support at the economy
is the right call um but it does have to
sort of end
at some point and i suppose the concern
is if the vaccine isn't rolled out it's
less effective there are third and
fourth
waves quite how long we're going to be
able to keep this up i
i really don't know it's almost as if
like the fast forward button has been
pressed with the economy on certain
changes that were happening anyway
with the high street with outsourcing do
you think that's a good way of looking
at it
usually when some big big changes happen
big crises occur
what they do is make things happen
quicker than they otherwise would have
done rather than change the direction
altogether
and i think probably that's what's
happening here there was a bit of a move
to working at home there was clearly a
move from
high street to online retail
um there may be maybe other changes
which go a bit in the different
direction we were still flying more and
more
it may be that firms discover that well
if people do this stuff from home why do
they have to be in the uk
at all so there may be a change actually
in the location
of some of those jobs i think there is
some hope in all of this i mean
lots of whilst lots of people have
struggled through this crisis
lots of you know saved loads of money
because there'd be nothing to spend on
so there's potentially um a big wall of
cash coming at some businesses in some
parts of the economy
through next year as people breathe a
sigh of relief and spend some of that
pent up savings so it might not all be
bad
but for some groups and for some sectors
of the economy they are going to need
support for
possibly some period covert 19 has
transformed how we work
shop and socialize as with all economic
shifts particularly ones that are
happening at breakneck speed
change could bring opportunity but many
jobs and livelihoods
will be devastated in the process